one of the most bizarre cabinet meetings
ever was held today I'm watching did you
hear about this turn about it it's very
strange because this never happens
president Trump held a cabinet meeting
today in which each cabinet member they
went around the room each cabinet member
took turns praising the president which
is not what happens at a cabinet meeting
they just went around each one praised
him yeah
after hearing this Kim jong-un said man
even I'm not that insecure that's that's
not a cabinet meeting that's like a
baby's birthday pay notice that he loved
it he had a little hat on and everything
over the weekend in New Jersey president
Trump crashed a wedding yeah
crashed a wedding probably the bride
said she wanted something old something
new something borrowed and something
that will probably be out of office by
August it's been reported that the
president Trump is so worried about
protests that he is postponing his
upcoming trip to England he's postponing
his trip to England yeah Trump's also
worried he doesn't have time to learn
the language
he's working on it stuff oh this is big
First Lady Melania Trump has officially
as of today moved into the White House
in a related story Donald Trump just
moved from the Lincoln Bedroom to the
Lincoln couch
yeah I think ever like yeah this
applause think teams the department this
is very strange the Department of Health
and Human Services just hired a woman
who is a prominent advocate of
abstinence only sex Edie yeah man
man who did she have to not sleep with
to get that job that's yeah that's that
was clever that was glad very clever a
new study reveals more than 2 billion 2
billion people worldwide are overweight
or obese
2 billion yeah and at any given time
most of them are at Disneyland the same
day as you apparently yeah apparently
apparently not such a small world after
all you see
oh well the joke was fine but that was
too much we're leading you've gone this
route hey get this someone invented a
pair of yoga pants that vibrate when
your yoga pose is incorrect which
explains the new trend in correct yoga
poses
did you enjoy watching me do that right
there I had to watch it on the monitor
and look at it in real life a series of
micro orgasms all right just talking to
myself now let's dump in big story in
the entertainment world after a
three-year feud Katy Perry has decided
to make up with Taylor Swift yeah yeah
Katie said that even though she still
believes strongly in a Keynesian
paradigm of economic output being
influenced by aggregate demand she
finally accepts Taylor's endorsement of
a supply-side macroeconomic model yeah
she also regrets calling Taylor a basic
[ __ ]
you
you